you mentioned that there might be some
fundamental limitation to the human
brain yes that limits our ability to
understand some aspect of how the
universe works that's really interesting
that's
sad actually if if to the degree it's
true it's sad so what do you mean by
that I would simply say that just as
um a monkey can't understand quantum
theory or even Newtonian physics
um there's no particular reason why the
human brain should evolve to be well
matched to understanding the deepest
aspect of reality
and I suspect that there are maybe
aspects that we are not even aware of
and couldn't really fully comprehend
um but as an intermediate step towards
that one thing which I think is very
interesting possibility is the extent to
which AI can help us I mean I think uh
if you take the example of uh so-called
theories of everything one of which is
string theory String Theory involves
very complicated geometry and structures
in 10 dimensions
and it's certainly in my view on the
cards that
the physics
of ten dimensions
they're very complicated geometry
um maybe too hard for a human being to
work through but could be worked through
by an AI
um with the advantage of the huge
processing power which enables them to
learn World Championship chess within a
few hours just by watching games so
there's every reason to expect that
these um machines could help us to solve
these problems and of course if that's
the way we came to understand where the
string theory was right
um is we in a sense frustrating because
you wouldn't get the sort of aha Insight
which is the greatest satisfaction from
doing science but on the other hand if a
machine churns away a 10-dimensional
geometry figuring out all the possible
uh origamis in Bound up in extra
Dimensions if it comes out at the end it
spews out the correct mass of the
electron the fact that there are three
kinds of neutrinos something like that
you would notice there was some truth in
the theory and so we may have a theory
which we come to trust because it does
protect things that we can observe and
check but we may never really understand
the full workings of it to the extent
that we do more or less understand
um
how
um
most phenomena can be explained in a
vital way of course in case of quantum
theory many people would say
understandably there's still some
mystery if you don't quite understand
why it works but there could be deeper
Mysteries when we get to these unified
theories where there's a big gap between
what a computer can print out for us at
the end and what we can actually grasp
and think through in our heads yeah it's
interesting that the idea that there
could be things a computer could tell us
that is true
and maybe you can even help us
understand
why it's true a little bit Yeah but
ultimately it's still a long journey to
really deeply understand the whys of it
uh yes that's an imitation of our brain
we can try to sneak up to it in
different ways given the limitations of
our brain have you I've gotten a chance
to spend the day a deep mind talked to
Demus lasabis his big dream is to apply
AI
to the questions of science certainly to
the questions of physics have you gotten
a chance to interact with them well I've
known quite well I've uh he's one of my
heroes certainly and I remember I'm sure
he would say this and I remember the the
first time I met him he said that he was
like me he wanted to understand the
universe but he thought the best thing
to do was to try and develop Ai and then
with the help of AI he's done more
chance of understanding the universe
yeah and I think he's right about that
so and of course uh um although we're
familiar with the the way his computers
played go and chess
um he's already made contributions to
science through uh understanding protein
folding better than her best human
chemists and so already he's on the path
to showing ways in which computers have
the power to learn and do things by
having a bit to analyze enormous samples
in a short time to do better than humans
and so um I think he would resonate for
what I've just said that it may be that
in these other fundamental questions the
computers will play crucial role yeah
and they're also doing uh quantum
mechanical simulation of electrons
they're doing uh control of uh high
temperature plasma Fusion reactors yes
that's a new thing which is very
interesting that they can suppress the
instabilities in these tokamax
um better than any other way yeah and
it's just the march of progress by AIS
and science is it is making uh big
strides do you think an AI system will
win a Nobel Prize in the century what do
you think
does that make you sad if I can digress
and pushing a plug for my next book yes
it has a chapter saying why Nobel prizes
do more harm than good yes so on quite
separate subjects I think uh Nobel Prize
is to aggressive damage to the
perception of the way science is done of
course if you ask who or what deserves
the credits for any scientific discovery
it may be often someone has an idea a
team of people who works experiment Etc
and of course it's the quality of the
equipment which is um crucial and
certainly in the subjects I do in
astronomy
um the huge advances we've had uh come
not from us being more intelligent than
Aristotle was but through as having far
far better data from powerful telescopes
on the grounds and in space and also
incidentally we've benefited hugely in
astronomy from computer simulations
because
um if you are
a subatomic physicist then of course you
crash together the particles into being
accelerator like the one at CERN and see
what happens but um I can't crash
together to galaxies or two stars and
see what happens but in the virtue world
of a computer
one can do simulations like that and the
power of computers is such that these
simulations uh can yield
um a phenomena and insights which we
wouldn't have guessed beforehand and the
way we can feel we're making progress in
trying to understand some of these
phenomena why galaxies have the size and
shape they do and all that is because we
can do simulations
um tweaking different initial conditions
and seeing which gives the best fit to
what we actually observe and so that's a
way in which we've made progress in
using computers and incidentally we also
now need them to analyze data because
one thinks of astronomy has been
traditionally a rather data poor
subjects but the um European satellite
called Gaia has just put on line the um
speeds and colors and properties of
nearly 2 billion stars in the Milky Way
and we do fantastic analyzes of and that
of course could not be done at all
without just the number of currency
capacitors computers and the the new
methods of machine learning actually
love raw data the kind that astronomy
provides organized structured raw data
yeah well indeed because of the reason
they really have a benefit over us is
that they can learn and think so much
faster that's how they can learn to play
chess and go that's how they can learn
to diagnose lung cancer better than a
radiologist because they can look at a
hundred thousand scans and if in a few
days whereas uh no human Radiology sees
that many a lifetime